shortly after four o'clock this morning  i spoke to president zielenski of  ukraine  to offer the continued support of the uk  because our worst fears have now come  true  and all our warnings have proved  tragically  accurate president putin of russia  has unleashed war in our european  continent  he's attacked a friendly country without  any provocation  and without any credible excuse  innumerable missiles and bombs have been  raining down on an entirely innocent  population  a vast invasion is underway by land  by sea  and by air  in concert with our allies we will agree  a massive package of economic sanctions  designed in time to hobble the russian  economy  and to that end we must also  collectively cease the dependence on  russian oil and gas that for too long  has given putin his grip on western  politics  attack military massive control ukraine  foreign  uh  in  b